ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
BILL [inaudible]
BURGESS [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
CAL YELLOW [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
DOT [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
GROW [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HILL [inaudible]
WITH SO [inaudible] FOR TITLE
[inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
LET [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONNING [inaudible]
MORE LOCKED [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN YOU KNOW [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible]
WHY CASKEY [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
WILK.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT WHAT THE
MEMBERS AT OUR GUESTS BEYOND THE
GALLERY BE ON THE REAL AND IN
THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE WE'LL BE
LEAD IN PRAYER THIS AFTERNOON BY
A GUEST CHAPLAIN SISTER MARIA
CAMPOS.
AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING WILL BE LED IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
BY SENATOR MCGUIRE [inaudible]
IT'S ON GOD OF LOVING KINDNESS.
AND MERCY WE ASK YOU.
THE QUIET EARTH THAT OUT OF
STILL SPACES WE MAY HEAR YOUR
VOICE.
MANY WALK IN FAITH ALL I DAYS
AWARE OF THE INTERDEPENDENCE OF
ALL LIVING THINGS.
AND COME TO KNOW YOU AND
EVERYTHING AND AND EACH OTHER.
QUIET AS BOTH SILENT WORD.
THAT OTHER STILL SPACES WE MAY
HEAR YOUR VOICE.
FROM THE GALAXIES AND THE FOR
THE STARS. TO THE SMALLEST ADAMS
IN OUR HEARTS.
YOU ARE THE LIVING FLAME OF LOVE.
MAYBE SEE YOUR DIVINITY IN.
THE WITHIN.
AND THE WITH OUT OF ALL THINGS.
QUIET AS BOTH SILENT WORD.
OUT OF STILL SPACES WE MAY HEAR
YOUR VOICE.
GATHERS TOGETHER --
HEALING PRESENCE.
THAT WE MAY LIVE IN PEACE AND
WITH ALL PEOPLE.
AND BRING GLORY TO YOUR NAME
[inaudible]
AMEN.
BETTER PRESIDENT.
SENATORS DISTINGUISHED GUESTS
PLEASE JOIN US IN THE PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
[inaudible]
A THERE ARE [inaudible]
LAW.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS WE'RE
GOING TO IF THE PRIVILEGES OF
THE FLOOR.
SENATOR PORTANTINO DO YOU HAVE A
PRIVILEGE OF THE FLOOR.
MR PORTANTINO CENTER PORTANTINO
AT THE MAJORITY LEADER'S DESK
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS --
COLLEAGUES TODAY I'M HERE TO
HONOR AND RECOGNIZE THE
CALIFORNIA EDUCATIONAL THEATER
ASSOCIATION.
ON THEIR TWENTY FIRST ANNUAL
CALIFORNIA YOUTH IN THEATER DAY.
AND THEY'RE RIGHT BEHIND ME THIS
IS GOOD --
WHICH BRING STUDENT PERFORMERS
AND TEACHERS FROM ALL OVER THE
STATE CAPITOL TODAY I'M JOINED
BY A MAN THIS.
MICHAEL DESPOT OURS ELDEN KLEIN
AND STACY CASSIE OWNING.
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY SIX MORE
THAN THREE THOUSAND STUDENTS
HAVE TRAVELED TO SACRAMENTO TO
PERFORM YOUTH IN THEATER DAY THE
STUDENTS DISTINGUISH THEMSELVES.
AS THE FUTURE OF THANK YOU AS
THE FUTURE OF ARTS AND
ENTERTAINMENT BUSINESS THESE
TALENTED YOUTH PARTICIPANTS ARE
AWARD WINNING THEATER STUDENTS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
WHO WILL PERFORM MONOLOGUES
SCENES SONGS AND DANCES DISTRICT
DEMONSTRATE THEIR CREATIVE
EXPERTISE TO THE LEGISLATIVE
COMMUNITY THE CALIFORNIA YOUTH
AND HERE TODAY CONNECTS AND
INSPIRES A GROWING COLLECTION OF
ARTISTS EDUCATORS AND SCHOLARS?
COMMITTED TO TRANSFORMING YOUNG
PEOPLE AND THE COMMUNITIES
THROUGH THEATER ARTS PLEASE GIVE
A WARM SENATE WELCOME TO THE
CALIFORNIA YOUTH EDUCATIONAL
THEATER ASSOCIATION.
WELCOME HERE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE.
MAY PRESENT A RESOLUTION PLEASE
PROCEED THANK YOU
.
THANK YOU SENATOR PORTANTINO
[inaudible]
SENATOR HERTZBERG.
SENATOR HERTZBERG AT THE PRO
TEM'S DESK.
THERE HERTZBERG AND HIS OWN DESK
OF DAYS PROCEED.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU SO VERY VERY MUCH
MADAM PRESIDENT YOU KNOW.
WE ALL GET.
OPPORTUNITIES IN THIS JOB TO DO
THINGS THAT --
MAKE OUR HEARTS SAYING AND TODAY
IS ONE OF THOSE THINGS FOR ME.
A GROUP OF STUDENTS HERE
[inaudible]
ALL WOMEN.
A GROUP OF STUDENTS AND MOTHERS
AND TEACHERS STARTED THE GLOBAL
ROSE UP REVOLUTION IN THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY.
BUT I REPRESENTS.
MANY FILMS ARE MADE IN THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY EACH YEAR.
BUT IT'S NOT EVERY DAY THAT THEY
ARE PRODUCED BY HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS.
AND IT'S NOT EVERY DAY THAT THEY
WIN AN ACADEMY AWARD LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN.
WHAT I WOULD SUGGEST IN THAT IT
IS NOT JUST THAT THEY WON THE
AWARD BUT IS THE SUBJECT OF
THEIR FILM THAT IS SO
[inaudible]
IMPORTANT.
THESE EXEMPLARY YOUNG WOMEN.
FROM OAKWOOD HIGH SCHOOL.
WITH THEIR ENGLISH TEACHER
MELISSA BURTON.
ARE PART OF A SCHOOL CLUB.
IT BEGAN AS A CHAPTER OF GIRLS
LEARN INTERNATIONAL.
THE PROGRAM OF THE FEMINIST
MAJORITY FOUNDATION.
THEY WANT TO THAT NATION'S
LEARNING ABOUT SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT ARE FACED BY
WOMEN.
YOUNG WOMEN THROUGHOUT THE WORLD
AND START EVENTUALLY TURNED
THEIR EFFORTS INTO WHAT IS KNOWN
AS THE PAD PROJECT.
A NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION WHICH
AS I SUGGESTED JUST ONE IT'S
AWARD FOR DOCUMENTARY FILM
ENTITLED PERIOD.
END OF SENTENCE THE PAD PROJECT
IN THE DOCUMENTARY ARE CREATED.
HAS A NOBLE IMPORTANT GOAL.
DE LEGITIMIZING MINISTRATION.
I'M HERE TODAY COLLEAGUES TO
TELL YOU THAT MINISTRATION IS
NOT A FEMALE ISSUE IT IS A HUMAN
ISSUE.
IT IS PART OF ALL OF OUR LIVES
IS PART OF OF FERTILITY IS A
FUNDAMENTAL PIECE OF WHO WE ARE
AS HUMAN BEINGS.
BUT ACROSS THE GLOBE THIS PIECE
OF HUMANITY IS USED TO OSTRACIZE
YOUNG WOMEN.
AS RESULTS EVEN OTHERWISE SO
CALLED CIVILIZED SOCIETIES.
WOMEN FACE SERIOUS HEALTH RISKS
BECAUSE OF LACK OF INFORMATION
ABOUT MENSTRUATION AND LACK OF
PROPER HYGIENE.
PRODUCTS.
THE PAD PROJECT IS WORKING TO
STOP THIS THEIR MOTTO.
A PERIOD SHOULD END A SENTENCE
NOT A GIRLS EDUCATION.
AS THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS IN A
NUMBER OF THESE COUNTRIES.
THESE INCREDIBLE YOUNG WOMEN
HERE TODAY HAVE FUNDRAISED TO
PURCHASE PAD MACHINES FOR RURAL
INDIAN VILLAGERS.
WERE ADMINISTRATION SO TABOO
THAT A WOMAN IS ARE BANNED FROM
ENTERING TEMPLES AND SOMETIMES
THEIR OWN HOMES.
BECAUSE OF IT.
THINK ABOUT THAT.
THESE STUDENTS OF COMMUNITY THAT
THEY SPEND THEIR TIME AND ENERGY
HELPING YOUNG WOMEN JUST LIKE
THEMSELVES MORE THAN EIGHT
THOUSAND MILES AWAY.
BECAUSE SAY THEY SEE AND HAVE
SEEN THIS ISSUE IN A HUMAN TERMS
THAT AFFECTS ALL OF US NO MATTER
WHAT PART OF THE WORLD YOU LIVE
IN.
THE PAD PROJECT IT IS ACADEMY
AWARD -- IS
GET IT'S ENTITLED PERIOD END OF
SENTENCE WHICH SHOWS THEIR
INCREDIBLE WORK THEY HAVE DONE
FOR WOMEN IN INDIA AND SINCE THE
DOCUMENTARY WAS RELEASED LAST
YEAR.
THE PAD PROJECT IS INSTALLED TO
MORE PAD MACHINES IN INDIA AND
PLANS TO CONTINUE THE WORK
INTERNATIONALLY.
AND I SINCERELY ENCOURAGE ALL OF
YOU IF YOU HAVEN'T DONE SO YET
IS TO WATCH THIS VERY SHORT BUT
INCREDIBLE DOCUMENTARY.
I'D LIKE TO CONGRATULATE THE
STUDENTS OF OAKWOOD HIGH SCHOOL
IN THE PET PROJECT FOR THEIR
WORK AND EMPOWERING WOMEN ACROSS
THE WORLD.
AND FOR THEIR TEACHER MELISSA
BURTON AND HERE TODAY WHO WENT
TO INDIA.
AS PART OF THIS ARE MAYES ARE
MASON MAXIMUS HERE WITH HER
MOTHER MAGGIE --
NAOMI -- Z.
BACK.
OF MORROW WORSE.
DOROTHEA MAKENI AND LEAH
SUGARMAN PLEASE LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN.
GIVE THEM YOUR GREATEST RESPECT
FOR THE UNBELIEVABLE WHAT
RESERVATIONS LADIES WALK FROM
YOUR CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
AND AFTER SESSION THEY'LL BE A
SORT OF A SECTION IF YOU WANT TO
COME AND VISIT WITH THEM FOR
BOTH ASSEMBLY AND SENATOR
SOMEBODY MEMBERS AND SENATORS.
UPSTAIRS IN MY OFFICE SO AGAIN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
CONGRATULATIONS WE HAVE A
RESOLUTION HERE SOMEWHAT ONE
MOMENT.
IT IS IN HER HERTZBERG ONE
SENATOR MITCHELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE --
FOR ACKNOWLEDGING THE PHENOMENAL
WORK OF THESE YOUNG WOMEN
COLLEAGUES ITS PLAN RIGHT NOW ON
NETFLIX IT'S ABOUT THIRTY
MINUTES SO THERE'S NO REASON WHY
EVERYONE HERE SHOULDN'TTAKE A
LOOK -- IT
WAS A MOVING EMOTIONAL PIECE OF
ART AND YOU ARE ALL YOU ALL ARE
TO BE CONGRATULATED A NUMBER OF
MY COLLEAGUES AND I TRAVELED TO
INDIA WITH THE SENATE OFFICE OF
TRAVEL --
THIS PAST FALL AND SO WE WERE
FAMILIAR WITH THE GENERAL --
SURROUNDINGS.
AND THE CULTURE THAT I SAW --
I COULD NOT.
NOT SPEAK TO THE ISSUE TO ALL OF
US AS POLICY MAKERS IN
CALIFORNIA AND AS A WOMAN --
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE RECOGNIZE
THAT YOU DON'T HAVE TO GO AS FAR
AS INDIA TO CONFRONT THIS ISSUE.
THIS IS A FUNDAMENTAL ISSUE OF
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE HAVES
AND THE HAVE NOTS.
AND WHILE THE ISSUE THE YOUNG
WOMEN TRADE IN THE MOVIE DEALT
WITH.
CULTURAL AND RELIGIOUS TABOOS
WHAT WE HAVE HERE IN THE GREAT
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WITH THE
FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE
WORLD.
IS AN ISSUE OF AFFORDABILITY.
UP WE'VE DEALT WITH THIS ISSUE
IN THE DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
WERE WOMEN INMATES WERE GIVEN
LIMITED ACCESS TO APPROPRIATE --
ITEMS THAT THEY NEED ON A
MONTHLY BASIS SANITARY NAPKINS
AND I HAVE TO SAY OF THE YOUNG
WOMAN. TO SEE YOU WALL AND TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WE MY SEAT MATE --
THAT A SHORT COULD BE FOUND IN
BE THE BRAIN CHILD OF YOUNG
WOMEN AND AS THE FILMMAKERS WHO
ACCEPTED THE ACADEMY AWARD TO
SAY THAT THEY CAN SAY ON THAT
STAGE AND SAY THE WORDS PAD
ADMINISTRATION WE'VE COME A LONG
WAY.
THE THING BACK TO OUR OWN HIGH
SCHOOL EXPERIENCE ABOUT THAT THE
SHAME THAT WAS ASSOCIATED --
WITH WTH NATURE SO I WANT TO
TIP MY HAT TO CONGRATULATE YOU I
HOPE THAT YOUR WORK WILL
CONTINUE HERE LOCALLY AND I
REALLY WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT MY
COLLEAGUES RIGHT HERE KNOW THAT
YOU DON'T HAVE TO GO SO FAR AS
TO INDIA. TO RECOGNIZE THAT
YOUNG WOMEN STRUGGLE WITH THIS
EVERY DAY CHECK WITH YOUR OWN
SCHOOL DISTRICT TO SEE HOW MANY
ABSENCES THEY THEY KNELT MONTHLY
FOR YOUNG WOMAN WHO DON'T SHOW
UP TO SCHOOL AND ASK THE
QUESTION WHY.
THE CONGRADULATIONS YOU ALL MAKE
US VERY PROUD
MEMBERS WE'RE
STILL UNDER PRIVILEGES OF THE
FLOOR SENATOR WIENER DID YOU
HAVE A PRIVILEGE OF THE FLOOR.
SENATOR WIENER AT THE PRO TEM'S
DESK.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT I COLLEAGUES I TOOK
GREAT PLEASURE THAT I WELCOME
THE LEADERSHIP OF THE GOLDEN
GATE BRIDGE HIGHWAY AND
TRANSPORTATION DISTRICT --
TO THE SENATE CHAMBERS --
THE DISTRICT IS NOT ONLY THE
CARETAKER OF ONE OF OUR STATES
MOST ICONIC LANDMARK SUPPORTS
THE GOLDEN GATE BRIDGE --
BUT IS ALSO THE LARGEST OPERATOR
OF COMMUTER FURRIES AND THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
IN ADDITION THE DISTRICTS FLEET
OF HYBRID AND RENEWABLE DIESEL
BUSES I CARRY PASSENGERS FROM
SAN FRANCISCO AND MARIN COUNTY
TO DESTINATIONS FAR TO THE NORTH --
HERE WITH US TODAY ARE SABRINA
HERNANDEZ THE PRESIDENT OF THE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS HI JOE COCKER
IN THE WHO IS A MEMBER OF THE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS.
THAT A SMALL AGAIN WHO'S THE
DISTRICTS GENERAL MANAGER --
AND I MOROCCO LONG THE SECRETARY
OF THE DISTRICTS OF PLEASE JOIN
ME IN GIVING A WARM SENATE
WELCOME.
WELCOME YOUR CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE
.
THANK YOU SENATOR WIENER MEMBERS
WERE STILL UNDER PRIVILEGES OF
THE FLOOR.
SENATOR RUBIO.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS IT IS MY PLEASURE TO
WELCOME DR MARYLAND ROSE OPERATE
TO THE CHAMBERS REPRESENTING
GREAT FALLS.
A KEY BUSINESS INTEREST IN MY
DISTRICT AND THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA.
DOCTOR ALSO BRACERS AS GRAPPLES
CHIEF MEDICAL OFFICER AND VICE
PRESIDENT OF QUALITY REGULATORY
COMPLIANCE IN LABORATORIES
CRIPPLES IS THE GLOBAL LEADER IN
PLASMA DONATION CENTERS.
MANAGING TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
SIX IN THE US AND EUROPE.
THE COMPANY PRODUCES PLASMA
DERIVED MEDICINES AND TREATMENTS
FOR RARE DISEASES SUCH AS
HEMOPHILIA.
PRIMARY IMMUNE DEFICIENCIES
GENETIC CHRONIC OBSTRUCTIVE
PULMONARY DISEASE AND ARE AGING
COMPATIBILITY THAT PLACES
CERTAIN WOMEN AT RISK OF
PREMATURE CHILD DELIVERY.
DOCTOR ALSO BRAY IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR OVERSEEING CRIPPLES CRITICAL
CENTERS AROUND THE COUNTRY AND
IT'S GOING NUMBER OF CENTER
THINK CALIFORNIA MADE MORE
FEASIBLE IN PART BY LEGISLATION
PASSED BY THIS BODY AND SIGNED
BY THE GOVERNOR LAST SESSION.
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING DOCTOR MARYLAND ROLE
SEPARATE TO OUR CHAMBERS THANK
YOU.
WELCOME TO YOUR CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE.
SENATOR GLAZER DID YOU EVER
PRIVILEGE OF THE FLOOR.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS OTHER STUDENTS IN THE
HOUSE TODAY STUDENTS IN THE
HOUSE AND THE SENATE.
HAS MANY MEMBERS KNOW.
STUDENTS FROM AROUND CALIFORNIA
HAVE BEEN UP HERE TODAY.
MEETING WITH YOU AND YOUR STAFF
TO CONTINUE THE IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION.
ABOUT STUDENT NEEDS.
STUDENT FINANCIAL AID.
HOUSING HUNGER AND MANY OTHER
CRITICAL ISSUES ON OUR CAMPUSES
WERE GRACE WITH SOME OF THE
STUDENT LEADERS HERE AND ARE
SENATE CHAMBERS TODAY WE WELCOME
YOU TO THE SENATE.
AND MEMBERS JOIN ME TO COLLAGEN
OR WONDERFUL STUDENT LEADERS
HERE IN THE CAPITAL.
WELCOME YOUR CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE.
MEMBERS WERE STILL UNDER
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR SENATOR
BRADFORD.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I AM
HONORED TO WELCOME THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF BLACK
LAWYERS BETTER KNOWN AS CABLE
HERE TODAY --
CABLE WAS A FORTY TWO YEAR
ORGANIZATION THAT'S COMPRISED OF
AFRICAN AMERICAN ATTORNEYS FROM
ALL ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IN VARIOUS FIELDS
FROM PRIVATE PRACTICE BOB
DEFENDERS THROUGH.
OUR D. A.'S --
THERE SOME OF THE BRIGHTEST AND
AND THEY'RE JOINING US HERE
TODAY AND I'M HONORED TO
RECOGNIZE THE PRESIDENT.
DAMIEN BROWN AND HIS POURED A
MELINDA MURRAY AND YOU MIGHT
KNOW LAST NAME MURDERED THE DART
OR WILL IT MARIE FORMER SENATOR
KEVIN MURRAY.
AND ODD ATTORNEY ROSS AND I'M
DRAWING A BLANK ON BUT THAT WE
HAVE A LOT IN THE GALLERY SO
LET'S GET MODE --
WOKE A CALIFORNIA WELCOME.
TO WELCOME YOUR CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE.
THANK YOU MEMBERS THAT WILL
CONCLUDE OUR PRIVILEGES OF THE
FLOOR MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
WILL BE DEEMED READ.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMD READ REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED.
MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE
[inaudible]
WE
WE HAVE ONE GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENT MATT APPROACH HIM
WOULD YOU LIKE TO TAKE THAT UP
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
SENATOR WILK.
PLEASE PROCEED ONE MOMENT MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
NEVER MIND PLEASE PROCEED MISTER
WELK THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS.
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE IS THE
CONFIRMATION AS SUSAN FINELLI AS
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH.
I MISS --
FINELLI PREVIOUSLY SIR FOR THREE
YEARS AS A DEPARTMENTS ASSISTANT
DIRECTOR.
ISSUES HELD VARIOUS POSITIONS AT
CD PH.
AND THE FORMALLY NAY DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH SERVICES SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND TWO SHE WAS
UNANIMOUSLY APPROVED BY THE
RULES COMMITTEE ON FEBRUARY
TWENTIETH.
PRICE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER WILK MEMBERS
ANY DISCUSSION SEEING AND
HEARING THAT MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA.
BY ATKINS.
AYE BATES.
AYE BELL.
I POOR JUST [inaudible]
I BRADFORD.
HI KELLY GYRO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
I DORADO [inaudible]
BY GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
BY GROWTH.
BY HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO BY --
TADA.
I JACKSON.
I JONES.
BY LEYVA HI BUY MCGUIRE.
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MONNING.
I'M MORE LOCK.
I'M A REAL [inaudible]
BY NELSON [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
HI PORTANTINO.
I ROTH BY RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
BY STERN [inaudible]
BY STONE [inaudible]
BY AMBERG.
BY WHAT COUNTY.
BY WINNER.
HI WILK.
HI.
NO THREE NINE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
THAT'S FINE [inaudible]
CHIANG.
NUMBER NINE I THIRTY SEVEN NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES ARE THE
APPOINTMENT IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WERE NOW GOING TO REAP
MOVED TO SENATE THIRD READING
ITEM FOR SENATOR PAN.
PASS SOME FILE WILL NOW MOVE TO
ITEM [inaudible]
SEVEN CENTER BORDERS.
PASS ON FILE.
ALRIGHT WE'RE NOW MOVING TO OUR
SPECIAL CONSENT CALENDAR.
PRIOR TO TAKING THE SUB MEMBERS
IS THERE ANYTHING THAT YOU WOULD
LIKE TO REMOVE FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ALL ITEMS
ON THE CALENDAR.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY FOUR
AND A SOME CONCURRENT RESOLUTION.
TWENTY SEVEN VERY GOOD PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON THE FIRST ITEM
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS AYE BATES.
BY BILL BY PORGES.
HI BRADFORD.
HI KELLY EURO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD.
HI THERE ALSO [inaudible]
HI.
GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER.
BY GROWTH.
AYE HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO BY OUR TOTAL
[inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
BY JONES.
HI LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE.
AYE MITCHELL.
AYE MONNING.
BY MORE LOCK [inaudible]
BY MERRELL [inaudible]
I NIELSEN.
I PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO [inaudible]
BY ROTH [inaudible]
BY RUBIO [inaudible]
BY SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE [inaudible]
BY HAMBURG.
HI MY COUNTY.
BY WINNER [inaudible]
BY WILK [inaudible]
HI.
I WAS THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS ARE THERE ANY COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS.
IS HUMAN SERVICES MEETING AT
SOME POINT TODAY YES SENATOR HER
TADO.
THANK YOU. FOR PURPOSES OF
ANNOUNCEMENTS EMMETT SENATE
HUMAN SERVICES WILL BE MEETING
IN ROOM TWENTY FIFTY AT THREE PM.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER ANNOUNCEMENTS SEEING
NONE WE WILL GO TO MOTIONSAND
RESOLUTIONS OF THE APPROPRIATE
TIME FOR A JOURNEY AND MEMORIES
SENATOR WIENER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HIS ME THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT --
THIS I JOIN A MEMORY IS FOR
MYSELF AND ALSO --
FOR SENATOR.
SKINNER --
COLLEAGUES IS WITH GREAT SADNESS --
THAT I RISE TO HOUSE AT THE
SENATE FIVE TESTS ROTHSTEIN ON A
VIBRANT YOUNG WOMAN WHO WAS
TAKEN FROM US.
WHILE BIKING TO WORK IN SAN
FRANCISCO ON FRIDAY MORNING.
I TASK TO IS A WAS A RESIDENT OF
BERKELEY.
WORKED AS A RESEARCHER FOR
MEDIUM AND AIRBNB FOCUSING ON
USER EXPERIENCE AND DESIGN.
SHE WAS KILLED ON FRIDAY MORNING
WHILE BIKING IN THE SOUTH OF
MARKET NEIGHBORHOOD.
WHEN SHE WAS STRUCK BY A
COMMERCIAL TRUCK NEAR THE
INTERSECTION OF SIX AND HOWARD?
HER DEATH IS YET ANOTHER TRAGIC
EXAMPLE AND WE THOUGHT FAR TOO
MANY OF THESE EXAMPLES.
OF HOW ARE CITIES FELL TO
PROTECT CYCLISTS AND PEDESTRIANS.
IN FAVOR OF CARS.
WE DESPERATELY NEED MORE
PROTECTED BIKE LANES IN SAN
FRANCISCO AND ELSEWHERE.
SO THAT WE HAVE SAFE STREETS.
THEY PROTECTED BIKE LANE WOULD
HAVE SAVED PASSES LIFE.
NO MORE EXCUSES.
TESS IS MOURNED BY HER FRIENDS
HER CO WORKERS AND A VERY VERY
LARGE COMMUNITY.
WITH PEOPLE SAYING THINGS LIKE
HOUSE WAS A QUOTE MODEL OF
CONFIDENT CURIOUS.
AND COMPASSIONATE HUMANITY FOR
ALL OF US.
COLLEAGUES I ASKED THAT WE
ADJOURN INTESTINES MEMORY TODAY.
AND I FURTHER ASK ABOUT HER
TRAGIC DEATH SERVICE A STRONG
IMPETUS TO MAKE OUR STREETS
SAFER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR WIENER CENTER
SKINNER.
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES SORRY RISE
TO ALSO ADDS TO THE JOURNEY
MEMORY FOR MY CONSTITUENTS TEST
ROTHSTEIN.
AND OUR COLLEAGUE FROM CIRRHOSIS
CODE DID DESCRIBE.
WHO SHE WAS WELL TO YOU --
BUT I WANT TO ADD.
THAT WE WE DO NEED TO DO MUCH
MORE ABOUT.
CYCLIST AND PEDESTRIAN SAFETY
SAFETY.
I DON'T HAVE DATA ON INCREASING
DEATHS PER SE.
BUT IT IS WAY TOO COMMON WAY TOO
FREQUENT.
AND JUSTIN BERKELEY ALONE MY
COMMUNITY CAN CYCLISTS WERE HIT
BY CARS.
IN FEBRUARY. ELEVEN RORY NOT ALL
WERE FATALITIES.
BUT THAT'S HOW MANY AND IF I
GIVE YOU PEDESTRIAN.
THE NUMBER OF PEDESTRIANS THAT
WERE HIT.
JUSTIN BERKELEY ALONE.
IT WOULD BE HARD TO A TO BELIEF.
SO.
I THINK IT REALLY IS INCUMBENT
UPON US BECAUSE ALL OF US WANT
TO BE ABLE TO DO ACT OF
TRANSPORTATION WITHOUT RISKING
OUR LIVES.
IN WITH CAR SAFETY IMPROVED SO
GREATLY WE DON'T WANT TO FEEL
LIKE THE ONLY TIME WE ARE EVER
GOING TO BE SAFE IS IN A CAR --
SO IT IS COMPLETELY TRAGIC THE
TEST ROTHSTEIN LOST HER LIFE IN
THIS WAY MY HEART GOES OUT TO
HER FAMILY AND HER FRIENDS AND I
THINK MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
FRANCISCO. FOR ASKING US TO TURN
IN HER MEMORY.
THANK YOU SENATOR SKINNER SIR
WIENER PLEASE MAKE SURE HER NAME
IS BROUGHT FORWARD THANK YOU
[inaudible]
SENATOR ATKINS.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES I RISE TODAY TO JOIN
IN MEMORY OF FORMER SAN DIEGO
CITY COUNCIL MEMBER JUDY MCCARTY.
SHE PASSED AWAY ON MONDAY MARCH
FOURTH AT THE AGE OF SEVENTY
EIGHT AFTER AN EXTENDED ILLNESS.
COUNCILMEMBER MCCARTY WAS ONE OF
THE LONGEST SERVING CITY COUNCIL
MEMBERS IN SAN DIEGO HISTORY.
REPRESENTING DISTRICT SEVEN
WHICH I NOW REPRESENT IN THE IN
THE SENATE. FOR FOUR CONSECUTIVE
TERMS FROM.
NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE TO TWO
THOUSAND AND ON A PERSONAL NOTE
HI I WAS A STAFF MEMBER.
AT CITY HALL WHEN JUDY WAS A
COUNCIL MEMBER I WORK FOR
CHRISTINE KEY HOUSE.
AND JUDY WAS ONE OF THE MOST
EVER MEET.
AND SHE REPRESENTED A COMMUNITY.
OF CITY HEIGHTS ALONG WITH THERE
WERE THREE COUNCIL MEMBERS --
CHRIS KEY H<c.cyan>UDY MCCARTY AND</c>
GEORGE STEVENS REVEREND GEORGE
STEVENS.
I WAS GOOD AT IT THREE PEOPLE
SPLIT THAT COMMUNITY I KNOW WE
TRY TO KEEP COMMUNITIES TOGETHER
AND THAT'S KIND OF A FACET OF
REDISTRICTING.
BUT THAT COMMUNITY HAD --
MORE THAN NINETY FIVE THOUSAND
PEOPLE EIGHTY FIVE LANGUAGES AND
DIALECTS SPOKEN.
AND THE LOWEST AVERAGE MEDIAN
INCOME -- IN
THE CITY.
AND TO HAVE THREE COUNCIL
MEMBERS FROM THREE DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVES AND POLITICAL
PERSUASIONS FRANKLY REPRESENT
THAT COMMUNITY MEANT THAT THERE
WAS A REAL FOCUS ON THAT
COMMUNITY.
AND JUDY --
WAS ONE OF THE HARDEST FIRST
THAT I WAS ABLE TO LEARN FROM.
A COLLEAGUE.
AND A FRIEND UNTIL THE END SHE'S
FINALLY REMEMBERED FOR HER WORK
TO INVEST IN SAN DIEGO'S PUBLIC
INFRASTRUCTURE ESPECIALLY PARKS
AND LIBRARIES.
WHICH ARE VITAL TO BUILDING
COMMUNITY AND QUALITY OF LIFE
COLLEAGUES ON THE CITY COUNCIL
REMEMBER HER AS HARD WORKING NO
NONSENSE TYPE OF LEADER.
TRUE TO HER MIDWESTERN ROOTS SHE
SPOKE SOFTLY BUT SHE WAS SOLID
AND SERIOUS IN HER WORK AND HER
CAUSES.
AMONG HER MANY ACCOMPLISHMENTS
SHE WAS PERHAPS MOST PROUD OF
HER WORK ON BEHALF OF MISSION
TRAILS REGIONAL PARK I HOPE YOU
ALL HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY. TO
VISIT THAT PARK I IT CONTINUES
TO BE A POINT OF PRIDE FOR OUR
COMMUNITY AS THE LARGEST CITY
PARK IN AMERICA.
BEFORE SERVING ON THE CITY
COUNCIL JUDY WORK FOR COUNCILMAN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND SENATOR
LARRY STERLING.
AS A DISTRICT REPRESENTATIVE AND
AS CHAIR OF HER LOCAL COMMUNITY
PLANNING GROUP.
SHE WAS BORN IN HAMMOND INDIANA
IN NINETEEN FORTY WENT ON TO
GRADUATE WITH A DEGREE IN
JOURNALISM FROM INDIANA
UNIVERSITY WHERE SHE ALSO MET
HER FUTURE HUSBAND KURT MCCARTY.
JUDY MCCARTY IS SURVIVED BY HER
HUSBAND CURB HER SON TO WIPE HER
DAUGHTER KATE AND FIVE
GRANDCHILDREN SO COLLEAGUES
PLEASE JOIN ME.
IN HONORING THE MEMORY OF DUTY
MCCARTY THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR
ATKINS PLEASE MAKE SURE HER NAME
IS PROP FORWARDS WE CAN PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZE HER.
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY FURTHER
BUSINESS.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE CENTER
ATKINS THE DESK IS CLEAR.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT WE
WILL RECONVENE AT NINE AM ON
THURSDAY HAVE A WONDERFUL WEEK
COLLEAGUES.
MEMBERS THE SENATE WILL BE IN
RECESS UNTIL THREE THIRTY AT
WHICH TIME THE ADJOURNMENT
MOTION WILL BE MADE WE WILL
RECONVENE THURSDAY AT NINE AM
HAVE A GREAT DAY EVERYONE